I like small cars better than big cars.
Smaller cars are easier to maneuver and easier to find parking spots for.
Some people say that small cars do not have enough trunk space, but they do!
I have no problem carrying my groceries.
I think many women would feel the same as I do,...
...but men like big cars, don't they?
Not me!
Actually, I completely support the points you just made.
I have driven a big sedan before.
The car was so long that I couldn't park it anywhere!
Compact cars are definitely the way to go.
Do you know what else is good about small cars?
They get great mileage!
My friend has a huge SUV and he fills it up once a week.
I go to the gas station about once every two weeks.
Driving a smaller car is a great way to save money.